قد اعلن الرئيس الروسي وفلاديمير بوتين ان
روسيا على استعداد لمواجهه التحديات
العالميه مع الدول المهتمه بذلك وقال في
كلمه وجهها الى المنتدى الدولي للمسؤولين
عن قضايا الامن بموسكو ان العالم يواجه
حاله من عدم استقرار متزايد نتيجه لرغبه
واشنطن وحلفائها بالحفاظ على هيمنتهم على
حد قوله
ميت
الوضع الدولي الحالي يتسم بالاعدام
الاستقرار في مناطق مختلفه تتوسعه التوتر
القديمه وتظهر بؤر جديده تشهد شعوب العديد
من الدول نتائج ماساويه لانقلابات نظمت من
الخارج ويرجع ذلك الى حد كبير الى رغبه
واشنط وحلفائها في الحفاظ على هيمنتهم
متجاهلين تماما سيادته ومصالح الدول
الاخرى بلادنا مستعده للتعاون الوثيق جدا
مع جميع الدول المهتمه بمواجهه التحديات
المشتركه